the Joe Rogan experience well she's a
weird one right because she has so many
characteristics that you would think
that everyone who was a progressive
would want as president she is a veteran
who twice served overseas took twice
deployed she's been a veteran for a long
time long time congresswoman she's from
Hawaii she's I mean I guess she's
Hawaiian you would say she's a woman of
color they say she's a woman of color
what color it's like she's Tanner than
me is she well she lives in Hawaii
that's why yeah I don't know about these
things I'm white I don't know it is
really I mean the Hawaiian roots are
essentially Polynesian and South Pacific
travelers who landed thousands of years
ago on those islands so yeah I mean it
is essentially a person of color either
way she's in a very articulate
rock-solid
woman and they've tried to find a bunch
of dirt on her and they can't and they
and they don't know what to do and it's
just funny to me that a lot of people
who were supporting Elizabeth Warren
were [ __ ] on Tulsi as hard as they
can and of course Elizabeth Warren shows
her true colors she does a right wing
sexist smear on Bernie Sanders is what
happened was weird this is such what a
crazy was it makes me like nobody's
buying that so it was it was heard the
media and the DNC got together and
they're like hey let's do this cuz it
was coordinated this didn't come out of
nowhere right and the CN n to see that
story CNN wrote these two people who
heard it from these other two people who
were not even gonna name and that's on
CNN that's CNN that's how they do it
it's so great yes they're digging their
own grave though what they're what
they're doing is they're making
themselves less and less relevant and
they're making guys like you and
independent people more and more
relevant and more and more trustworthy
and that's why they keep going to the
catnip of Russia gate or Joe's tweets or
whatever at Peach mint and this phone
call to the thing and you know look how
they look how the media runs
interference for the establishment it's
amazing like you know to pretend that
the Biden's aren't corrupt I know and to
have people come on and go that's a lie
that's no corruption it's been looked
into there's no corruption that a guy
has an $83,000 job on a board in a
country his dad just helped overthrow
what are you [ __ ] crazy it seems like
it might be
corrupt well the conversation where he
tells the prosecutor that if if he's not
gone you don't get the billion dollar
right what do you know they fired the
guy right you saw that video so yeah I
saw that video and did but the defense
to that is they're saying but that
prosecutor was corrupt and the next guy
was even more tougher of an investigator
but that guy was investigating verismo
at the time yeah and that guy it did say
later that guy who got fired said I got
fired because I was investigating BER is
Moe he said that in a court document so
believe me they're all Crider why didn't
they why didn't they impeach Trump on
the emoluments clause why didn't they do
that why did they do it on what's the
law and so that's him benefiting off his
position in government it's cuz they all
do it why do you think because it would
bring up everything it would have to
that's right hey Hillary Clinton I mean
Chelsea Clinton just got a nine million
dollar job for her she deserves oh my
god she did she did the best so then
people are saying that people are saying
what's wrong with the woman using her
degree she has three degrees I wonder
how she was at for able to afford those
three degrees I wonder she overcame all
those obstacles did she did yeah so if
they're all corrupt that's that's then
that's the story and that's why we
handled Trump clinging to this system
that's why we don't have a functioning
medical system or a functioning banking
system because Barack Obama was paid off
by the bay by the health insurance
companies and the Wall Street banks and
that's not me saying that that's Dylan
Ratigan an award-winning Bloomberg
reporter says that how'd they pay him
off uh well he has a I don't know if he
noticed he just bought a house at
Martha's Vineyard from the guy who owns
the Celtics he says yes forty has 49
acres he's got a lot of money
forty-nine that's more acres than Kevin
Hart wow that's a lot of acres yeah
that's that's the guy who's a community
organizer I guess it was a gated
community how does that work how does
that work where it's legal like how does
how does the the president get pushy
when he left tot when he left the
presidency he goes windsurfing with
Branson for a while right as we still
don't have clean water in Flint and
and when he comes back in the public
life the first thing he does he goes
make speeches for equity firms we had a
half a million a pop yeah for 20 minutes
Pete what do you think that is what do
you think all this is this a bribe
what are you going after the fact yes
yeah but it's amazing that they still
honor that that they're so rock-solid in
their commitment to this corrupt system
that even after the guy can't even help
him anymore he's out of office they hook
him up with these speaking jobs right he
gets a half a million bucks a pop and
then whatever he wants to do yeah wasn't
that a thing about the Clinton
Foundation where Bill Clinton would he
would make sure that he got speaking
gigs along with the weapons deals that
she was giving yes yeah this is correct
yeah everybody's again they're dirty we
didn't get Trump because the Democratic
Party was doing their job right their
people were got desperate and decided to
take a chance on a political novice game
show host who they knew was a
bullshitter
everybody knows Trump's a bullshitter
they were that good go [ __ ] those
people we hate yeah and that's to see
and I I've been imploring that Bernie
campaign which nobody listens to me so
it doesn't matter why don't they listen
to you I don't know maybe because I
communicate in a caustic way Joe but I
I've been trying to burnish is should be
wiping the floor with these candidates
he that shouldn't even be close right
Minh so I've been employing them
Bernie take the gloves off would you
quit turning to Joe Biden and saying my
best friend Joe Biden you got to do what
Trump did what Trump was running he ran
against the Republican Party he ran
against all those pukes that the people
are sick and tired of that the people
have been let down by these are the
people who took you to Iraq these are
the people who took you to Libya these
are the people who are bankrupting you
these are the people so that's what he
did and and you know Bernie gets up and
he goes drunk my good friend I just want
you know you're corrupt it's like quit
saying you're friends with these [ __ ]
guys to our corrupts quit do just what
he could land it he should turn and I've
been begging he came close in the last
debate he kind of killed it in his voice
tell what she said I'm not good at
impressed he's pretty good praise the
best but he got right there that was a
pound one Joe Biden
the reason why you can't understand how
medicare-for-all works is because you're
corrupt and you're paid not to
understand and we're gonna get rid of
your brand of corruption when I'm
president because you're the problem
mmm oh my god people would go crazy the
place would go [ __ ] crazy and
Elizabeth Warren would stand up for Joe
Biden that's almost sexist right and
everybody would see what the game is
wasn't he like always in the morning
Elizabeth Biden yeah Elizabeth Biden
Elizabeth Warren wasn't he always in
support of her Joe Biden yeah no no no
no Bernie Sanders yeah they was always
in support yes
so Elizabeth Warren was like hey
Bernie's policies are pretty popular
I'll pretend like they're mine yeah well
she was a Republican people forget until
she was 47 years old Yeah right forget
that yeah well Bert while Bernie was
running around telling people that a
woman could be President she was still a
Republican yes
[Applause]